[Music]
you're from new jersey originally yeah
you came out here to los angeles when
you were 12 12 yeah and you said you you
started uh doing stand-up here actually
oh really yeah you're very funny and you
you're very good with accents too yes
and you're standing well thank you i
think that's nice of you i'm not sure if
i am but uh i do i did i i was actually
recently i was talking about british
people on uh on stage and i got into a
little bit of an altercation uh with
with a british guy oh they don't like it
you know i don't know man i insulted i
was just talking about you know i was
doing the accent i was like you know
british people i was just having fun
whatever
being a real idiot oh you know this is
how british people are this is what
british people do
and uh that's my stand up basically for
an hour and uh
it kills and uh
yeah
and so this guy uh and he got upset
because what were you saying about
british i don't even remember i was just
kind of going with it at the time and at
the uh afterwards at the show he was
like i've got to talk to you for a
second he's like first of all we don't
all talk like that
and i was like i was like yeah well that
is fine but you definitely have to
change your voice because that's exactly
what i was doing on stage
and when british people threaten you you
don't know what they're talking about
it's in english but they just say things
you don't know if it's good or bad or
what they'll just be like you keep
talking to me like that you keep yapping
off at the nana's you see what happens
you keep chomping i'm clambered so get
the stoozy boys to roll up on you i'll
leave you halfway up main street if your
pants around your ankles and a lollipop
in your mouth
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you're like awesome is that a party yeah
is this a bad thing that's gonna happen
you keep talking like that i'll come
over bright and early and literally do
great work in your bathroom
you're like for free i'm dead